senator ted cruz great state of texas
senator i can only hope
i don't count
any vote take any election for granted
but certainly you can't point to a
single thing that joe has done that's
successful at least i can't maybe you
can yeah no sean you're exactly right it
is amazing how this president this
administration has managed to get every
single policy wrong from economic policy
to domestic policy to foreign policy
in in some ways you have to marvel
that they managed to screw everything up
if they literally threw darts at a wall
they'd get something right and yet
across the board galloping inflation
crime out of control chaos at our
southern border
gas prices five six seven dollars all of
these are the result of wild out of
control liberalism and and i think the
american people are really fed up i
believe november is going to be a title
wave look i agree with mark penn you
were just quoting bill clinton's
pollster who says this is going to be an
election like 1994 this is going to be
an election like 2010. i think
republicans are going to win the house i
think we're going to win the senate i'll
make a prediction right now i believe
this election south texas which has been
a democratic bastion for a hundred years
i think south texas is turning red this
election because you cannot defend the
disaster that is this policy and you
know it was striking to me when biden
gave his state of the union a couple of
months ago
that they didn't attempt to make a
u-turn they didn't attempt to correct
look you don't have to be a political
genius to realize they're off track
we all remember bill clinton what an
amazing
political tactician he was it was
frustrating but he managed to pull
himself out of the fire more than once
and the state of the union was the great
opportunity to do that
biden doubled down on the build back
broke problem prop program on higher
taxes on open borders he doubled down on
failed policies and i think that's going
to lead to an amazing election in
november you know it's interesting you
know as one of the highest approval
ratings of any senator joe manchin joe
manchin stood up against biden you know
what his approval rating in west
virginia is like 60 joes is 33 as
national average according to quinnipiac
um let me go back to the other issue and
that involves twitter and the meltdown
over elon musk you know all of a sudden
liberals are now saying they're afraid
that people with different political
views on the left that they might get
canceled on twitter voices might be
silenced and i'm like well where have
you been the last number of years
because conservatives have been living
this nightmare for the entire time and
not one of these people one time ever
stood up and said what you're doing by
banning donald trump whether you like
him or don't like him is wrong or or
shadow banning conservatives or any or
or hiding the hunter biden laptop story
is just simply wrong your thoughts look
that is exactly right i think elon
musk's buying twitter is without
exaggeration the most important
development for free speech in decades
big tech
is an existential threat to free speech
and free and fair elections in america
and and there's a dynamic that has
played out for decades which is
conservatives win
when we effectively communicate what we
believe because our ideas work free
enterprise works freedom works liberals
win when they effectively obfuscate what
they believe when they hide what they
believe and that means they want to
censor they want to silence voices you
know some time ago i had the ceo of
youtube sitting in my office and and she
was saying we were talking about stephen
crowder who's the the the right-wing
libertarian comedian he's very funny a
lot of young people like him youtube
demonetized it and and she was saying
well you got to understand a lot of
people on the left wanted us to ban them
all entirely we didn't do that and i
responded i said hold on a second this
is not tit for tat we're not asking you
to silence liberals i don't want you to
silence bernie sanders or aoc i want
people to hear them because we win on
free speech if i want to hear
conservative ideas i follow sean hannity
and i'll tell you something really
promising last two weeks my podcast
verdict with ted cruz we were on campus
at university of alabama we were on
campus at yale had five to six hundred
students a third of them were liberals
people want to hear truth and substance
and the final point i want to say
congratulations on being the longest
late night tv host in history beating
out larry king larry king was 142 years
old sean you're a kid compared to that
but you're doing a hell of a job and and
the country's grateful as rocky once
said i got a lot left in the basement
i'm not done yet senator i got a lot in
the basement anyway thank you you're
very kind